Trascrizione: Ottavia Merlin
Revisore: Ilaria Cubalchini
Siamo abituati a pensare all'abuso di cibo
soltanto in termini di obesità,
quando ne mangiamo troppo.
Invece il problema, oggi,
è l'abuso di informazione.
Usiamo male le informazioni circa il cibo.
Quindi ci perdiamo la magia
e smettiamo di pensare, di immaginare,
che possiamo essere dei veri maghi.
Come?
Possiamo immaginare che il cibo funzioni.
Sembra banale? Eppure no.
Non ci accorgiamo che, quando mangiamo,
quello che mangiamo,
nel nostro corpo, si comporta
proprio come un cartone animato.
Entra e fa un effetto.
La funzione del cibo nel nostro corpo
non è così banale,
perché istantaneamente cambia, modifica
il funzionamento di ogni cellula
dei nostri organi.
Che cosa significa questo?
Significa che siamo in grado,
ad ogni pasto,
di innescare una reazione che possa essere
verso la salute o verso la malattia.
Oggi, il killer vero
si chiama sindrome metabolica.
La sindrome metabolica è chiamata
la "madre dei killers",
che sono le malattie cardiovascolari,
il diabete, il cancro, l'Alzheimer,
il Parkinson e tante altre.
Croniche e degenerative.
Bene, questa sindrome è legata a un grasso
che si chiama grasso viscerale.
Voi potete pungere la vostra pancia
e prendere del grasso che è sottocutaneo.
Non vi piace? Eppure il grasso viscerale
è dentro, non lo vedete,
ma pensate che un grasso viscerale
che pesa veramente poco
è in grado di produrre
tre volte le molecole
le sostanze proinfiammatorie,
della stessa quantità
di grasso sottocutaneo.
Quindi oggi ci dobbiamo preoccupare
di quello che ci accade dentro,
che dipende da quello
che mettiamo nel nostro piatto.
Poi dipende dall'ambiente,
dalla nostra genetica,
eppure abbiamo in mano
uno strumento fondamentale: il cibo.
Il cibo funziona
in base a come lo scegliamo,
lo prepariamo, lo associamo
e lo mettiamo nel piatto.
Quando si parla di nutrizione funzionale
stiamo considerando proprio questo:
Dobbiamo imparare a capire chi siamo
e costruire un abito su misura
attraverso la scelta del cibo
che possiamo mettere nel nostro piatto.
Questo è il cuore, il progetto ormonale.
Ogni pasto è un progetto ormonale.
Progetto ormonale
significa un network di ormoni
che istantaneamente
i nostri organi liberano.
Quindi lasciamo da parte
le mode e i metodi alimentari.
Immaginiamo, invece, di compiere la magia.
Non serve scegliere il cibo ottimale,
il cibo perfetto,
il cibo super, smart.
Sì, esistono anche dei cibi
che io chiamo "amici",
dei cibi buoni,
in grado, per esempio, di gestire la fame.
Perché la fame è un sintomo
di squilibrio ormonale.
Questi cibi sono in grado, per esempio,
di tenere bassa l'insulina,
che è uno degli ormoni principi,
causa la deposizione del grasso viscerale,
e quindi la sindrome metabolica.
Ma quello che è importante
è pensare "in unicum", in sinergia.
Costruiamo un pasto,
perché noi non mangiamo cibi,
ma mix di cibi, appunto:
un pasto, una ricetta.
La pasta al pomodoro non è "un" alimento,
è un mix di alimenti
cucinati in un certo modo
e proposti al nostro corpo
in un certo modo.
Eppure esistono degli alimenti speciali,
quindi l'optimum si compie
quando utilizziamo alimenti speciali,
magnifici, eccezionali,
ma li mescoliamo e li combiniamo insieme.
In questa combinazione di cibi
realizziamo quel progetto ormonale.
Il progetto ormonale è essenziale.
Quando si parla di nutrizione funzionale
si sta immaginando
un tipo di alimentazione
che controlla l'infiammazione silente.
È un processo infiammatorio continuo
che nel nostro corpo si innesca
e non finisce mai.
Costantemente, ogni giorno
invecchiamo, ci ammaliamo,
Dico sempre che tutti noi
dobbiamo guarire,
da quando nasciamo dobbiamo guarire.
Non esiste la prevenzione primaria
perché comunque sbagliamo qualcosa,
volenti o nolenti: l'ambiente, i geni,
quello che mangiamo.
Dobbiamo iniziare
il processo di guarigione.
Lo possiamo fare soltanto
se impariamo a gestire i nostri piatti,
ogni giorno, ogni pasto non gestito
è un'occasione mancata
per guadagnare salute
ed essere al 100% il meglio di voi stessi.
L'infiammazione cosiddetta "silente"
produce sostanze tossiche,
che si chiamano, per esempio,
radicali liberi.
L'infiammazione si produce
se mangiamo male,
se produciamo ormoni tipo l'insulina,
ma anche, per esempio,
se la flora batterica,
o meglio il microbioma intestinale,
produce dei metaboliti che non sono utili
e li riassorbiamo.
Anche qui reagisce l'alimentazione.
Quello che mangiamo è in grado di gestire
tutti i batteri, virus, funghi ed altro
che vivono dentro di noi,
e che sono in simbiosi con noi
per la nostra salute.
Quanti supplementi assumete ogni giorno,
sperando nell'amuleto magico?
Invece il vostro amuleto è nel piatto.
Anche il microbiota intestinale
gestisce questa infiammazione.
L'infiammazione silente,
oggi che si parla tanto di longevità,
è proprio questo:
ogni volta che scateniamo
un processo infiammatorio
abbiamo bisogno di riparare.
Ogni processo riparativo
consuma il potenziale di longevità,
che è scritto nei telomeri,
la parte terminale del cromosoma
che ogni volta che ripariamo
si accorcia di una sequenza.
Più si accorcia,
più la cellula alla fine non si riproduce.
È come giocare a un videogame:
consumate le vite.
Più siete infiammati, più vite consumate.
Quindi la longevità dipende anche
da quello che mettete nel piatto.
Oggi si parla molto di digiuno.
Non c'è bisogno di digiunare,
ma di imparare la strategia alla base.
Mimare il digiuno,
attraverso i cibi amici di cui ho parlato.
Che cos'è il digiuno?
Per esempio è un equilibrio ormonale
che ci consente di vivere a lungo e bene.
Possiamo raggiungerlo mimando il digiuno
coi cibi che mettiamo nel piatto.
Uno fra tutti?
Il controllo,
attraverso il mix di cibi giusti,
attraverso l'utilizzo di strategie
di preparazione del cibo ottimali,
il controllo dell'indice insulinico.
Magari alcuni di voi hanno sentito parlare
di indice glicemico, carico glicemico...
Lasciate perdere.
Pensate piuttosto in modo "ormonale".
Pensare in modo funzionale
significa proprio questo:
pensare all'azione funzionale
del cibo nel vostro corpo
e nel momento in cui parlate di funzioni
state parlando di organi.
Fegato, rene, pancreas, surrene, tiroide.
Pensate, nel vostro piatto
finiscono degli alimenti
che istantaneamente sono in grado
di condizionare il lavoro degli organi.
È entusiasmante.
Ecco la magia del cibo, è proprio questa:
essere in grado, ad ogni pasto,
di ricondizionare nuovamente,
di riscrivere un nuovo programma.
E quindi anche a questo
è legata la longevità.
Non serve fare anti aging,
o mangiare l'alimento magico
che ci mantiene in salute.
Ha più importanza il controllo insulinico,
questo ormone che
istantaneamente, ogni giorno,
finisce per essere prodotto
in maniera troppo eccessiva
perché i nostri pasti
non sono combinati bene insieme.
Chi mangia insieme
un piatto di riso e una mela?
Cibo perfetto, sano. E invece no.
Perché scatena e libera troppa insulina.
Allora è sbagliata la mela, forse?
È sbagliato il riso?
No, probabilmente non sappiamo cosa accade
quando questi alimenti
incontrano le nostre cellule,
come le nostre cellule reagiscono
e come i nostri organi
producono gli ormoni,
i messaggeri che li mettono in contatto.
Quindi non basta conoscere il cibo.
Nutrizione funzionale significa
partire da chi siamo,
da come funzioniamo,
e quindi da come il cibo riesce a
cambiare le nostre funzioni organiche.
Che significa "codice della vita"?
Significa:
aggiungere più vita ai giorni
e più giorni alla vita.
Vivere meglio oggi,
ma per vivere più a lungo.
È questo quello a cui
dovrebbe tendere ogni obiettivo,
medico e non medico.
A volte si pensa troppo in breve,
soprattutto nel mondo della medicina.
Facciamo tutto quello che è possibile fare
nell'immediato, risolviamo un sintomo.
Curiamo, non guariamo.
Attraverso la nutrizione funzionale
possiamo guarire perché siamo in grado
di combinare, nello stesso pasto
alimenti che siano in grado, ricordate,
di condizionare il lavoro degli organi,
l'equilibrio ormonale
e quindi l'infiammazione
e perciò di metterci nelle condizioni
di vivere meglio oggi
e vivere meglio domani.
In una parola,
questo è il codice della vita.
Grazie.